- This video is brought to
you by Full Sail University.
(upbeat music)
What's up guys, Michael here
and today I'm ready to
inspire a niche group
of otherwise charming adults
to write me evermore
elaborate death threats.
Welcome to part two of our
exploration of Disney adulthood,
where mouse ears are part of the lifestyle
and reciting Hakuna Matata
each morning is mandatory.
Last time we looked at
the scholarly debate
over how we talk about fandoms like Disney
and whether or not they
qualify as religion.
And despite the fact that
it might make some scholars
and all Disney adults,
very, very mad at us.
We're gonna take it a step further today.
We're going to examine the evidence
for Disney operating as a religion.
That means looking at the nuts and bolts
of how the hypothetical
church of Mickey Mouse works
and what its spiritual
doctrine might entail.
So buckle up for part two
of this Wisecrack Edition
on Disney adults, "Is Disney a Religion?",
but before we get into it,
I wanna shout out this video
sponsor Full Sail University,
Full Sail offers Associate's, Bachelor's,
and Master's degrees
in the fields of technology,
arts, media, and entertainment.
And they just launched
a new Bachelor's degree
in game business and eSport,
which can help students enter the industry
from different perspectives,
from game development,
to communications and marketing,
to competitive gaming itself.
And this new major joins a roster
of other cool fields of study,
like film production, computer
animation, sports casting,
and web development.
With Full Sail University's
accelerated coursework
you can finish your degree in
about half the time required
at other colleges and universities.
Plus, you can complete your
classes and coursework online
or in person at Full
Sail's campus in Orlando,
depending on what's right for you.
Whatever model you choose,
you'll get hands on real world experience
in the career path of your choice.
Plus full sale accepts
new enrollments monthly.
So you don't have to build your schedule
around traditional semesters.
To learn more about Full Sail University's
new game business and eSports majors,
or any of their other degree programs
visit fullsail.edu/wisecrack.
That's fullsail.edu/wisecrack.
And now back to the show,
remember our friend religious
scholar, Dr. Eichler-Levine,
who's passionate defense of Disney adults
inspired this video
series in the first place.
Well, she's far from the
first person to explore
the possibility that Disney
might constitute a modern day religion.
Way back in 1934, author Ian Forrester
went so far as to argue that
Mickey is everybody's god.
Meanwhile, scholar Richard
Foglesong called Disney
"The Vatican with mouse ears".
But in order to really determine
if Disney is a full blown faith,
we first need to think about
what makes something a
religion to begin with.
For our purposes,
we're gonna use anthropologist
Clifford Geertz's
popular definition from 1973,
which outlines five stipulations
to define religion as:
One, a system of symbols.
Two, about the nature of things.
Three, that inculcate
dispositions for behavior.
Four, through ritual and
cultural performance.
Five, so that the
conceptions held by the group
are taken as real.
Addressing the first piece.
A system of symbols look no further
than Mickey Mouse himself,
who has become a worldwide
symbol of innocence.
And the United States market
researchers have found
he has a 97% recognition rate.
Making him more recognizable
than Santa Claus.
As cultural critic, Henry Jeroh notes,
"The cultural iconography of Disney,
renders it a purveyor of
innocence and family fun."
He adds that through its films,
parks and endless merchandising,
"Disney becomes a symbol
for the security and romance
of the small town America of yesteryear"
From the iconic Cinderella's castle,
representing enchantment
and dreams coming true,
to barbershop quartets
strolling down Main Street, USA,
Disney is rife with symbolism,
not unlike that of religion.
They do some of this by operating as
what DePaul University
professor, Michael Budde,
might call "symbolic predators".
That is appropriating existing imagery
from traditional religions.
Indeed like the sun shining
over Simba's kingdom
echoes of world religions appear
throughout Disney properties.
Take the concept of the circle of life,
which is deeply rooted in Hinduism,
according to journalist, Mark Penske.
Or Snow White, taking
a bite from an apple,
like you know who.
Heck Penske points out that in Pinocchio,
when Geppeto falls to his knees
to ask an undefined deity for help,
a fairy appears conveniently decked out
in the Virgin Mary's
trademark shade of blue.
Still let's be clear,
explicit references are largely
absent from Disney movies.
This was intentional.
Disney biographer, Bob
Thomas, notes that Walt Disney
made the strategic business decision
to keep religion out of his films,
in order to make them marketable
to the widest international audience.
And yet, there's still
an argument to be made
for the second qualification for religion
about the nature of things.
Disney movies may not feature
an explicit God figure,
but many have argued that
Disney effectively poached
a lot of Judeo-Christian ideology,
while scrubbing out the
actual divinity stuff.
As Penske explained back in 2004,
"There is relatively little
explicit Judeo-Christian
symbolism or substance in 70 years
of Disney's animated features,
despite the frequent, almost pervasive use
of a theological vocabulary:
words, such as faith,
believe, miracle, blessing,
sacrifice, and divine.
It seems a contradiction,
portraying consistent
Judeo-Christian values
without sectarian or even godly context,
the fruits without the roots."
He points out that Disney
effectively preaches
the Protestant work ethic
minus the whole God thing.
Exemplifying the argument that hard work
leads to upward social
mobility, no matter what.
Echoes of the David and Goliath story
frequently pulsate through the films,
with the poor and downtrodden
always eventually triumphing
over the powerful and corrupt.
As Penske summarizes,
"Good is always rewarded;
evil is always punished.
Faith is an essential element,
faith in yourself,
and, even more, faith in
something greater than yourself,
some higher power.
Optimism and hard work
complete the basic canon."
Penske dubs this Disney
ethos "Secular Toonism",
explaining that in place of
God working his divine magic,
Disney uses magical
creatures doing magic magic,
you know, fairies and fairy godmothers,
genie and ice queen, sea
witches and land witches.
In this way scholar Kathy
Merlock Jackson writes,
"Magic becomes a way to
empower the powerless,
just like God does in so many
classic biblical stories."
So part two pretty much checks out.
Part three inculcating
dispositions for certain behaviors.
We're gonna set aside for now
and return to momentarily.
So we've established
that Disney essentially
created and maintained a
consistent system of symbols
about the nature of
things across its films,
parks and other products.
But how are those messages
imparted onto its believers?
Well as author Richard Corliss
speculated in a 1988
issue of Time Magazine,
"Walt Disney's philosophy
may as well have been
the Jesuit credo of 'give me
a child before he is seven,
and he will be mine for life'."
Indeed Disney said as
much, declaring that,
"I think of a child's
mind as a blank book.
During the first years of his life,
much will be written on the pages.
The quality of that writing
will affect his life profoundly."
By his own logic then,
Disney has been for multiple generations,
scribbling all over those blank minds.
With children spending more
time consuming Disney films
than they do with organized religion.
And of course, as many of
us grow out of childhood
and into our teens and adulthood,
Disney is right there to
accompany us on our journeys.
Except this time with
Jedis, and superheroes,
and bounty hunters, until
life gets so depressing
that we need the talking animals again.
And then we come to part
four of our definition,
ritual and cultural performance
by far the most salient place
where the rituals of Disney consolidate
is, of course, at its theme parks.
According to Harper's magazine's index,
an estimated 70% of Americans
have been to one of them,
which is probably the only thing
70% of Americans have in common.
These larger than life locations
are seen by some scholars
as akin to sacred spaces where
visitors make a pilgrimage,
not unlike that of Jews to
Jerusalem, or Muslims to Mecca,
or American Irish Catholics
to the Guinness brewery
at St. James Gate, Dublin.
Fittingly Disney's parks are absent
of the unholy banalities of real life
like litter, or swearing, or frowning.
Religion scholar, Mircea Eliadi,
describes the importance people of faith
ascribe to so-called sacred spaces,
i.e. places that seem to
exist in a sacred time,
that is when the world
was young and Edenic.
In these spaces, myth and
ritual help worshipers
by recalibrating life toward the divine.
As scholars, Eric Mazur and Tara Koda,
summarize in their book, "The
Happiest Place on Earth".
Notably as Drew points out Disney too
exists outside of time,
Hell, Disney reportedly
removed all alarm clocks
from its hotels in 2016.
More importantly, the
parks have no references
to the present, a few
references towards the future,
but mostly seem to exist in a past
that somehow approximates
Eisenhower's conservative America.
That is a time when the world was young.
Indeed Disney world was
attracting the nostalgia
of baby boomer parents long
before it became the site
of their millennial children's weddings.
Missing, of course, is anything
unpleasant about that era,
like the Red Scare, or
racism, or barbiturates.
In frontier land, the American
frontier is mythologized
as a place of courage and adventure,
making the brutal genocide
committed against native people
on those lands a brief footnote.
American history is further
glorified and sanitized
in places like the hall of the presidents,
where ugly parts of
history like say Watergate
or Iran Contra are ignored
as an animatronic Abe
Lincoln in Christ like glory
returns to life.
Historian Mike Wallace
calls this commercialization
of the past, Mickey Mouse history.
A narrative written "without
classes, conflict or crime,
a world of continuous consumption,
a supermarket of fun."
Innocence effectively
becomes a magic eraser
cleansing history of
its less savory moments.
And these Disney
narratives all come to life
in its holy sites.
Where rituals like riding Splash Mountain,
or watching sunset
parades down Main Street,
or getting your picture
taken with the characters
for a hefty fee, all
provide joy and catharsis.
In these spaces, religious scholar,
Peter Gardella writes,
"Magical beings like Tinkerbell
and Mickey Mouse abound,
and many shows imply that such beings
might help ordinary people."
Gardella calls this "trans-theism"
or "the provisional
acceptance of many gods
with an implied underlying oneness"
As with a religious service,
your sense of possibilities
for your life are expanded
through promises of divine intervention,
or at least the ear of a
sympathetic fairy godmother.
Giroux describes Disney as
a privatized, homogenous,
and risk free city.
Whereas critic Elaine Rapping points out,
"No trace of anything
non-comodified, non-simulated,
non-regulated non-smiley-faced,
is visible or reachable"
As with other sacred sites,
the sense of effortless
magic is facilitated as much
by what you don't see as by what you do.
A tour of the Pope's bathroom
might kind of ruin the vibe
of the Vatican after all.
Similarly, there's a virtual absence
of anything non magical at Disney,
most especially, visible labor.
Disney employees, sorry,
we mean cast members,
use underground tunnels to transport
food, products, and waste.
As Giroux concludes,
"Through the use of public
visual space, i.e. parks
like Magic Kingdom,
Disney's network of power relations
promotes the construction
of an all encompassing
world of enchantment,
allegedly free from ideology,
politics and power".
That's in spite of the fact
that political lobbying
is the reason that Disney World
was able to exist for so long
as a self-governing
independent special district.
The park paints itself as
a place of transcendence
of elevation beyond the
mundanity of everyday life,
which brings us to stipulation five.
"So that the conceptions held by the group
are taken as real."
Now, we're obviously not
saying that Disney adults
literally wish upon stars
or, work hard at their jobs
just because seven dwarves
of various dispositions
told them to,
but Disney's grand narrative
of spiritual uplift,
moral truth, and endless nostalgia
seems to be taken at face value
or filtered through the fervor
with which Disney adults
express themselves.
Disney adults may not pay tzedakah
at the temple of Tinkerbell,
but one popular Disney
world vacation tip site,
suggests that two adults have to cough up
between 1,900 and $2,800 to visit Disney,
which I'd call a healthy tithe.
Meanwhile, according
to the Washington post
Disney continues to hike prices
as much as five to 10% each year,
which is fine because wages
go up at the same rate, right?
That's how economics work.
Viewing Disney World as a
site for rights of passage
like weddings or bar and bat mitzvahs,
cements the sense of faith fans have
in the sanctity of its ethos.
Now let's return to
stipulation number three,
inculcating dispositions for behavior.
What, if any, sort of behavior
does the Disney empire
encourage in its supplicants?
You might be surprised actually
that we haven't really brought it up yet,
starts with C synonym for eat,
that's right, consumption,
and lots of it.
As American studies scholar,
Eric Smoodin puts it,
"Disney constructs
childhood so as to make it
entirely compatible with consumerism",
and it does so in the hopes
of creating lifelong patrons
of Disney entertainment
and related products.
Though, it's not the only
company to attempt such a feat,
Mazur and Koda argue that,
"Because of its market penetration,
it's integrated marketing
and its access to many levels of culture
through its corporate network,
Disney is uniquely suited
for the religification of its commodity."
This is important because as Giroux notes,
in our world of rapidly
evolving mass communication,
"Pop culture is a central
way for young people
to learn about themselves,
their relationship to others
and the larger world."
He argues that Disney is
perfectly suited for a world
where democracy has
come to be less defined
by civic engagement than by
the freedom to consume freely,
and be entertained.
Disney, he explains, prime
children to relate to themselves
as consumers, before citizens,
as individuals pursuing self-interest,
rather than members of
communities pursuing
any sort of collective good.
And then carry that
self-perception into adulthood.
Nowhere is this more
evident than a Disney world,
whereas Giroux explains,
"Consumption becomes
the unifying force through which families
organize themselves.
Disney theme parks, not only
provide middle class families
with an upbeat version
of the American past.
They give such entertainment,
the force of civic duty.
Encouraging spectatorship and passivity,
Disney appropriates nostalgia,
simply to maximize consumption
in the interest of fun and commerce."
All at the side of Mickey
mouse popsicles, of course.
Now, given Disney's ability to fulfill
all five stipulations of
Geertz's definition of religion.
It's easy to conclude that it is in fact
functioning like a religion,
even if unintentionally.
But there's still a bit more to unpack.
See, most religions ask
us to sacrifice things
in exchange for say salvation,
or God's good graces.
We're supposed to give our
money to houses of worship,
or charities, or spend part
of our weekends in prayer,
or deny ourselves the
pleasure of red meat,
or avoid masturbating
so the Pope doesn't show up to our house
and glue our palms to a cross.
Religions also typically ask us to strive
to abide by an ethical code,
and repent when we fail to do so.
But Disney's pitch is a bit more simple,
as Phil Vicher, co-founder
of Veggie Tails,
persuasively argues,
"Disney has wrapped up
and sold America what
people wanted to hear,
which was 'give us the upside of religion
without the obligation of religion'."
That is, like a lot of businesses,
Disney offers us enlightenment
through consumption
without asking us to do any
of the pesky self examination
that traditional religion might require.
The difference is, it just
happens to have a lot more power,
and of course, a lot more real estate
than most of the other
people trying to sell you.
At their parks, we can
enjoy all the spiritual
and ecstatic feeling of religious worship,
without having any of the
moral or ethical responsibility
that religion imposes upon us.
Disney's ideology is
ultimately pretty hollow,
and yet its cultural
reach is so expansive.
Its appeals to childhood
innocence so persuasive,
that we can easily forget.
It's not a value driven benevolent entity
striving to uplift its followers.
It's a profit driven
multinational corporation
as Giroux puts it, "Innocence
serves as a rhetorical device
that cleanses the Disney image
of the messiness of commerce,
ideology, and power."
That is to say, marketing
itself as an institution
in the business of enchantment,
can make you forget the immense
and ever growing choke hold
over the entertainment industry.
And it's obviously not just preaching
the gospel of Mickey for fun.
As Giroux furthers,
"That Disney has a political stake
in creating a particular moral order
favorable to its commercial interest
raises questions about what it teaches."
He argues that the lesson
plans at the school of Disney,
ultimately "reinforce an
infantalized and privatized
notion of citizenship."
Disney probably isn't consciously
trying to mimic religion,
but its approach to converting acolytes
can border on indistinguishable.
Let us repeat.
Disney is not trying to be a religion,
but it's tactics and the
reception it receives from fans,
often takes on a spiritual tinge.
Disney's interests are well served
when people buy its products,
but its interests are best served,
when a consumption driven population
is more concerned with
having fun in Disney world
than say, with the labor
rights of the workers
making the park happen in the first place.
Or the company's serial coverups
of sexual harassment and assault.
In our cynical day and age,
we all pretty much know
that giant corporations
basically never become giant corporations
because they've done things
in kind and magnanimous ways,
no matter how cute their mascot is.
And Disney is no different,
while it's been hosting
gay days since 1991
under the auspice of
celebrating the queer community.
It was also just recently
busted for donating money to
politicians who oppose queer rights.
That includes Florida
Republican, Dennis Baxley,
a career long champion
of anti-gay legislation,
and sponsor of the controversial
"Don't say gay" bill,
which limit school teachers
from mentioning anything queer
related in the classroom.
While claiming to be a
pride friendly company,
they've simultaneously
been funding politicians
who are actively harming
the queer community.
Now after public outcry,
Disney CEO Bob Chapek,
eventually spoke out
against the bill promising
to be a better ally
and announce that the company was pausing
political donations in Florida,
yet concurrently queer Pixar
workers published a statement
claiming that Disney higher ups insisted
they cut nearly every moment
of overtly gay affection
in their films,
suggesting the company's
allyship remains suspect.
And this is hardly the first of Disney's
questionable political affiliations.
They've also funded business groups
who actively fight climate
change legislation.
And a recent report found that 69%
of their political donations
went to anti-abortion politicians.
It's rainbow capitalism
at its most insidious.
Or take the time in 2013
as Disney was developing the movie Coco,
when they tried to trademark the phrase
"Dia de Los Muertos".
This is part of Disney's
gargantuan merchandising machine,
which dates back to 1937's Snow White.
You heard that right.
In the lead up to the release
of their groundbreaking
celebration of Mexican culture,
Disney tried to actively snatch the name
of a sacred tradition outta
the hands of the Mexican people
across multiple media platforms.
It's not good, team.
It's not good.
What's more the values espoused
in Disney films over the years
can leave a foul taste in the mouth
of a more progressive culture.
From blatant racism,
to tired tropes of princesses
being rescued by princes,
Disney has long been a protector
of white heteronormative ideology,
with much of the fantasy
that makes it so appealing
coming from a longing for an imagined past
of greater simplicity.
Despite Disney's attempts to
keep its nostalgia apolitical
there's nonetheless a
deeply political tinge
to its avocation of a better time.
Especially when you remember
that in this romanticized past,
many minority groups experienced
profound discrimination.
And while Disney is certainly
getting better about depicting
more diverse stories.
It's hard to outrun its legacy,
especially when those foundational films
and park attractions remain so popular.
So it looks like Disney has
successfully used aspects
of religion to maintain
its cultural power.
But that doesn't mean
that it's intentionally built a religion.
At the same time, it's the epitome
of a capitalist institution
and has always been most loyal
to the creed of maximizing profits.
So what exactly does that make it?
That question, like the
historic relationship
between capitalism and
religion in America,
is more complicated than you might think.
Dating back to the 16th
century Christian missionaries
who accompanied gold hungry
explorers on their excursions
to the new world.
Religious scholar, Robert
Lawrence Moore argues
that religion has evolved
alongside mass consumer culture
out of necessity, increasingly
commodifying along the way,
he writes that, "Religious
influences established themselves
in the forms of commercial culture
that emerged in the 19th century,
turning the United States
into a flowering Eden
of leisure industries by
the middle of the 20th."
Beginning with various sex, mass produced
and extensive religious reading materials,
religions expanded their wares
by entering radio and theater,
and eventually television
via televangelist
like Jim and Tammy Faye
Baker, Pat Robertson,
and Jimmy Swaggart.
They expanded beyond halls
of worship into nonprofits,
athletic clubs, like the
YMCA, social halls, and so on.
He explains that, "By
degrees, religion itself
took on the shape of a
commodity as it looked for ways
to appeal to all consumers,
using the techniques
of advertising and publicity."
At the same time,
religious institutions
have been notably exempt
from some of the governmental regulations
and limitations of other markets.
Moore notes, rightly
that flashing neon signs
promising "Jesus Saves"
would never get churches in
trouble for false advertising.
After World War II,
comodified religion poured
into American culture
at an unprecedented rate,
and culture responded in like
with a proliferation of
Hollywood blockbusters
based on biblical stories.
Around this time, America
saw the beginnings
of the megachurch, which
according to scholar,
Scott Thumma function like corporations,
with the pastor as the often handsome
and handsomely compensated CEO.
They brand themselves
like corporations too,
by offering disparate
attractive forms of fun,
performing arts, recreation
activities, gyms,
even movie theaters.
And don't even get us started again
on the enormous Christian music scene.
And it wasn't just Christianity.
From the sixties on,
hundreds of new age religions
flourished among free thinking boomers,
almost always with economic tie-ins
in the form of healing, spas,
crystals, and radio stations.
And this way as sociologists
Peter L. Berger has observed,
"Religious institutions
become marketing agencies
and the religious traditions
become consumer commodities.
And the good deal of
religious activity comes to be
dominated by the logic
of market economies."
In recent years, as Mazur and Koda note,
the line between religious activities
and commercial activities has
become increasingly blurry,
with unexpected crossovers
between the two realms
and everything from Christian MLMs
to Jewish dating sites.
Increasingly people like the
fourth best Hollywood Chris,
will identify not as
religious, but as spiritual,
a term that is inherently looser
and can be conducive to a
sort of grab bag approach
to spirituality.
Mazur and Koda concur.
Writing of Disney,
"They have entered the market
at a time when many people
are not only searching for alternatives
to traditional religion,
but are also flexible
with what they find."
So maybe the answer
ultimately is that Disney
is fulfilling functions of religion,
such as religious institutions
fulfill functions,
like fun and entertainment
that are typically associated with Disney.
So Disney's not necessarily
becoming more like religion.
Religion might just be
becoming more like Disney.
And nowhere is this bizarre paradox,
more apparent than at
one of the countries,
many Jesus themed parks.
But then again, maybe
we shouldn't see this
as strange at all because
capitalism as an economic theory,
has actually never been
totally free from religion.
Philosopher at Walter
Benjamin, famously said that,
"A religion may be
discerned in capitalism.
That is to say capitalism
serves essentially to allay
the same anxieties,
torments, and disturbances
to which the so-called
religions offered answers."
Which basically means that capitalism
isn't just an economic system,
but a set of beliefs that aims
to offer meaning and purpose
to modern life.
But rather than offering the
hope peace and justice often
promised by religion,
according to Benjamin,
capitalism, "is a religion which offers us
not the reform of existence,
but its complete destruction.
It is the expansion of despair
until despair becomes a
religious state of the world
in the hope that this will lead
to salvation."
In this context, all kinds
of profit driven institutions
could be seen as doing something similar,
i.e. offering their own
solutions to problems
previously thought to be
the realm of religion.
Whether you're preserving
your Hello Kitty lunch box
behind a wall of glass,
or worshiping at the altar
of your favorite CrossFit instructor,
praying with your model hot pastor
at an evangelical megachurch,
or spending your whole paycheck
at Disney's Animal Kingdom,
which why, it's the
saddest place in the world
because it's like a zoo,
but there's no way
they're taking care of it
the same way you would take care of a zoo.
It's really, it makes me feel bad.
Don't go to Animal Kingdom no matter what
just about every major
institution you're engaging with
is inevitably shining their lights
towards the goodness of our one true God.
Capital.
And as for Disney adults,
are they part of a religion?
Nah, not by our estimations,
but are they an excellent
example of the porousness between
consumerism and spirituality
that characterizes this moment in time?
Almost certainly.
But the good thing is, unless
you're the type of person
who uses up all your yearly vacation days
for trips to Anaheim and
Orlando, you are in the clear.
I guess, unless you're
really into Star Wars.
'Cause that's that's Disney now.
Or if you've enjoyed
the 29 or so MCU movies
and the growing number of MCU TV shows,
which are produced by Disney
and available on Disney plus.
But hey, if you're like a
sports person, then you're good.
Except for Disney owns ESPN.
So every time you watch Stephen A. Smith
lay down a hot take,
you're still playing
right into the, those,
the hands of the mouse.
Oh God. Okay.
At least I still have my guilty pleasure.
The bachelor and it's related properties,
which, damn it, they're on ABC,
which is owned by Disney too.
Jesus Christ or, or Jesus Mouse or,
or Mickey Christ I
don't even know anymore.
So maybe we're just all Disney adults now,
whether we realize it or not.
But what do you think?
do you welcome your mouse-eared overlord?
Or do we still have a chance to eek out
our own spiritual identities?
Let us know in the comments,
thanks to our patrons
for all your support.
Be sure to check out our new patron perks
if you haven't already and
be sure to check out our new
stream Wisecrack Live.
It happens right here.
Every Thursday at 11:00 AM pacific.
Smash that subscribe
button like it's a bell jar
protecting the enchanted
rose, keeping you alive.
And don't forget to ring that bell.
Be sure to like this video,
unless it's inspired
you to write hate mail,
and as always, thanks for watching.
Later!
(upbeat music)